en este problema nos preguntan cuál es
el área de esta figura y la figura que
nos dan pues es un cuadrilátero que
simétrico con respecto a una de sus
diagonales y a veces a los cuadriláteros
de este tipo se les conoce como
papalotes por razones obvias verdad
porque aparecen papalotes de esos que
luego uno va a volar al ajusco o vaya a
su monte favorito bueno entonces aquí
tenemos un papalote nos piden encontrar
el área nos da la longitud de una de las
diagonales y esto que podemos pensar
pues como la altura del papalote o bien
como la longitud de la otra diagonal
vale bueno para calcular el área de éste
papalote lo que vamos a hacer es cortar
la parte de arriba en cachitos y pegarla
en la parte de abajo para eso déjame
copiar la parte de abajo ya la tengo por
acá ahí está y ahora sí vamos a dividir
la parte de arriba en cachitos lo
primero que voy a hacer es trazar una
perpendicular desde este vértice a esta
diagonal entonces ahí nos va a quedar
una línea vale que divide la parte de
arriba en dos triángulos ahora en el
triángulo de la izquierda voy a pintar
esta base de color morado
- como rosa morado es más morado y voy a
pintar el interior del triángulo en
color rojo en color rojo vale entonces
ahí tenemos ya algunos colores hitos y
voy a hacer algo similar con el
triángulo de la derecha esta base la voy
a pintar color verde color verde ahí
tenemos esa base de color verde y el
interior de este triángulo lo voy a
pintar en color azul ahí tenemos el
color azul muy bien bueno ya que tenemos
estos colores podemos hacer un truco
bien padre vamos a empezar
concentrándonos en este triangulito de
acá lo que vamos a hacer con este
triangulito es voltearlo y pasarlo para
acá abajo eso lo podemos ver aquí es
decir este triángulo se va a convertir
en este triángulo de acá en este
triángulo de acá
saleh es este triangulito de acá tenemos
que este lado naranja ahora se va a
convertir en este lado de acá y
finalmente la base que pinte de morado
ahora va a ser esta de acá muy bien y de
manera similar lo que vamos a hacer es
este triángulo otra vez lo vamos a
voltear y lo vamos a colocar de este
lado entonces aquí tenemos el triángulo
azul tenemos el bueno el área que marque
en color azul por aquí tenemos el lado
que marca en color naranja
si este lado de aquí es el equivalente o
bueno es el correspondiente a este lado
de acá y finalmente tenemos la base
verde como está un poco larga voy a usar
la herramienta de recta está entonces
ahí tenemos este triángulo vale y la
razón por la cual estos triángulos caben
perfectamente es justo porque un
papalote simétrico este lado mide lo
mismo que este lado esta base mide lo
mismo que esta base y esta altura de acá
mide lo mismo que esta altura de acá
vale que esta altura de acá y lo mismo
con el otro triangulito entonces ya
tenemos reacomodadas nuestras piezas del
papalote para formar un rectángulo pero
este rectángulo pues ya está este pues
muy fácil de calcular su área verdad
tenemos que la base es de 14 centímetros
14 centímetros la altura no es 8 sino la
mitad entonces la altura es de 4
centímetros 4 centímetros
aquí ya quedó superado ordenado este
lado pero pero bueno así pasa entonces
tenemos base 14 altura 4 centímetros y
por lo tanto el área de este rectángulo
o bien del papalote es
por 4 14 por 4 que es igual a 4 x 4 es
16 llevamos una es igual a 56
centímetros centímetros cuadrados sale
entonces con esto calculamos el área del
rectángulo y por lo tanto el área del
papalote y básicamente lo que hicimos
para encontrar el área del papalote es
multiplicar esta diagonal con esta
diagonal y dividir entre 2 o bien
multiplicar esta diagonal por la mitad
de esta diagonal que es exactamente lo
mismo vale bueno espero que te haya
gustado este vídeo nos vemos en el
siguiente